А зараз - «heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом
та Ханною Ціммерман.
Доброго вечора всім!
Спекотно.
Навіть зараз, о 22:45.
37,1 °C сягала сьогодні температура в Німеччині.
42,9 °C - у Біарріці, у Франція.
Там це найбільш рання спека за останні 75 років.
В Іспанії лісові пожежі вже знищили
тисячі гектарів лісу.
Північ Італії страждає від найгіршої посухи
за останні 70 років.
У Великій Британії вже 3-й день поспіль
фіксують нові рекорди спеки для цієї пори року.
Хоча за календарем літо ще навіть не почалося.
Далі - Катрін Лінднер.
Лісова пожежа у Фронсдорфі,
що на південь від Берліна.
Гасити вдається лише на відстані.
У землі ховаються боєприпаси
з двох світових воєн.
Горить 80 гектарів лісу.
У федеральній землі Бранденбург цього року
було зафіксовано вже близько 220 лісових пожеж.
Сьогодні там змушені були оголосити найвищий
у Німеччині рівень пожежної небезпеки в лісах.
Такі температури разом із вітром
та великими площами хвойних лісів
за рівнем пожежної небезпеки
наближають цей регіон на Сході Німеччини
до країн Середземномор’я.
Річка Шпрее поблизу міста Котбус є
важливим джерелом водопостачання для Берліна.
Уже зараз річка потребує додаткової води
з водосховищ,
а в місті Котбус заборонили вдень
брати воду з річок та озер,
зокрема для приватних садів.
Минулого року, якщо я не помиляюся,
це почалося лише в кінці липня.
Але цього року навіть весна вже із самого початку
видалася дуже сухою.
А рівень ґрунтових вод в регіоні
знизився на 80 см
порівняно з попередніми показниками.
Цими днями вода важлива
не лише для навколишнього середовища,
але й для людського організму.
До клініки в Штутґарті через спеку
сьогодні звернулося багато пацієнтів.
Багато людей також консультувалися в телефонному режимі.
Усе частіше до нас доставляють пацієнтів,
передусім людей похилого віку,
зокрема з будинків для літніх людей,
тому що їм стає зле
через зневоднення.
Вони не могли пити або не пили достатньо,
тому потребують
введення рідини внутрішньовенно.
На території від південно-західної
частини Німеччини
аж до східної Саксонії
температура сягнула близько 35 °C.
Рослини страждають від посухи та спеки.
Ось, наприклад, поле поблизу Лейпцига.
Зміна клімату за останні десятиліття
була значно швидшою, ніж та,
яку ми очікували
відповідно до кліматичних моделей.
А це означає, що у світі насправді
все змінюється набагато радикальніше.
Той, хто цими днями перебуває надворі,
добре відчуває на собі всю суворість зміни клімату.
«Тепер він зможе зробити те, що завжди хотів», -
таке майбутнє AfD
зі старим і новим лідером Тіно Хрупаллою
окреслює представниця
більш слабкої частини партії.
Хоча на з’їзді партії
він і отримав найгірший результат
за всю історію подібних виборів в AfD,
проте з новою співголовою Аліс Вайдель
і бажаними кандидатами
на посади своїх заступників
він переміг так званих «поміркованих»
однопартійців.
Залишається незрозумілим,
у якому напрямку тепер рухатиметься AfD
після цілої серії невдач на місцевих виборах.
Давід Ґебгардт розкаже більше.
Попри такий поганий результат,
йому вдається приховувати розчарування.
Тіно Хрупалла - знову голова AfD.
З найгіршим результатом на виборах голови
за всю історію партії -
лише трохи більше 50%.
І керуватиме він не сам, як давно хотів.
Цю посаду з ним розділить Аліс Вайдель,
яка показала значно кращий результат.
Новий старий лідер партії каже,
що задоволений результатом.
Це прорив AfD, нам вдалося
об’єднати всі наші течії.
Тепер ми зможемо увійти в одне русло,
яке нас зміцнить.
Імовірніше, що це не русло, яке його зміцнює,
а течія, яка його терпить.
Лідер радикалів Бьорн Гьокке,
хоч сам і не підходить,
але спонукає своїх колег.
Нове керівництво партії
повністю відповідає моєму смаку.
Це смак ультраправого політика.
Такий прорив радикалів є катастрофою
для партійців з помірними поглядами.
Адже тут той, хто у своїх агітаційних промовах
вимагає помірності, зазвичай програє.
Нам потрібно терміново вибратися з тієї ями,
у якій ми зараз перебуваємо.
З новим стилем  політичної комунікації
та новою стратегією.
Щоб виборці бачили, що в AfD все-таки
відбуваються позитивні зрушення.
Ми повинні завоювати прихильність виборців.
Менше негативу, менше злості.
Але без злості на цьому з'їзді партії не обходиться.
Аліс Вайдель зрозуміла це,
й у своїй промові із насолодою висловила
своє невдоволення через дії ексголови партії,
чим викликала овації колег.
Тиждень тому Йорґ Мойтен
на широко анонсованій пресконференції
заявив про свій вступ
до католицької мініпартії «Центр».
Для цього він забронював розкішний зал у будівлі
для пресконференцій державного рівня в Берліні,
хоча для цієї «трагедії» вистачило б і сповідальні
в якій-небудь цвинтарній каплиці.
Епоха Мойтена сьогодні добігла кінця.
Це день розрахунку.
Радикали пообіцяли помститися, коли Мойтен
вигнав із партії ультраправого Андреаса Кальбіца.
Жодного з тих, хто тоді голосував, сьогодні немає.
Когось із них не вибрали, а когось - вигнали.
Після лютого «скидання шкіри»
один із таборів тепер остаточно поза грою.
Заява Тіно Хрупалли про бажання
відобразити в керівництві партії всі течії,
яку я сприйняв дуже радо, жодним чином
не відповідає дійсності.
Вибори програли, членів партії втратили,
стратегічно ослабли.
AfD у кризі намагається почати все заново.
Вона шукає зцілення серед радикалів.
Старий і новий голова AfD Тіно Хрупалла.
Доброго вечора, пане Хрупалло.
Доброго вечора, пане Зіверсе.
Сьогодні дуже спекотно.
Абстрагуючись від погоди, як сильно Вам довелося
попітніти, щоб залишитися лідером партії?
Мене було обрано із трохи більше,
ніж 53% голосів.
Перемога на виборах завжди дається непросто,
це стосується й AfD.
Я дуже задоволений результатом.
Але я також приймаю це зі смиренністю.
І якщо подивитися на той факт, що Фрідріху Мерцу
довелося балотуватися тричі,
щоб стати лідером партії, можна побачити,
що в AfD все набагато консолідованіше.
Однак тепер він є лідером партії, що знаходиться
на вершині політичного барометра ZDF з 26%,
тоді як AfD зазнала десяти поразок поспіль.
Пане Хрупалла, як людина,
яка була на посаді раніше,
ви хочете реалізувати оновлення партії.
Наскільки сприятливим є результат виборів
у 53 відсотки?
Ви знаєте, ми сьогодні обрали цілий Федеральний
виконавчий комітет,
де кілька людей представляють партію.
І це було моє завдання, і це була моя воля,
щоб ми об'єднали всі течії,
усі легітимні течії нашої партії.
І нам це вдалося.
І відсьогодні ера Мойтена закінчилася,
і кадрові дискусії теж закінчилися.
Наразі ми зосередимося на програмних пунктах
нашої партії.
Тепер ми будемо приділяти увагу турботам та
потребам Німеччини та її громадян,
а також зробимо політичну пропозицію
для цих людей,
щоб альтернативна партія знову піднялася і щоб,
звичайно ж,
партія AfD знову досягла
високих результатів на виборах.
Чи справді ви об'єднуєте всі течії,
коли пан Гьокке тепер каже,
що новий склад правління
«повністю відповідає моєму смаку».
Знаєте, сьогодні є загальні результати,
що перевищують 75 відсотків.
Цей склад правління відповідає і моєму смаку,
і також смаку багатьох делегатів.
Сьогодні вони ухвалили рішення.
Вони проголосували сьогодні.
Як я вже сказав, ми поєднали всі течії.
Зараз ми є сильним потоком.
Я думаю, що ми, як я вже сказав,
залишимо в минулому наші сварки,
які в основному були спричинені паном Мойтеном
в останньому Федеральному виконавчому комітеті,
і зосередимося на майбутньому.
Тепер ми маємо зайнятися вирішенням проблем
у Німеччині.
Тепер ми дбатимемо про інтереси Німеччини,
як усередині країни, так і за кордоном.
Нам потрібна не зовнішня політика,
орієнтована на цінності,
а політика, орієнтована на інтереси та благо німців,
щоб наші ціни на енергію знову знизилися,
щоб ми мали доступне житло і щоб можна було
фінансувати наші пенсії.
Це завдання майбутнього,
які ми знову робимо політикою
для наших громадян у Німеччині.
Пані Вайдель і раніше казала вам
«дозвольте мені зробити це»,
але якби мова йшла зараз про неї,
то й у неї сьогодні результат кращий, ніж у вас.
Чи є Аліс Вайдель тепер таємним,
справжнім лідером партії AfD?
Ви знаєте, ми з Аліс Вайдель працюємо разом
у дусі довіри та партнерства,
навіть у виконавчій владі
парламентської партії.
Ми були найкращою командою кандидатів на
виборах до Бундестагу
та були обрані з 72 відсотками голосів.
Ми підтримуємо один одного,
і кожен має слабку і сильну фазу.
Так, безперечно, буде і в майбутньому.
Ось як побудовані партнерські відносини,
так само і в політиці.
І ми відчуваємо підтримку з боку голосування
партійного з'їзду,
і ми продовжуватимемо успішно будувати
політику разом.
І це наше завдання на сьогодні.
Як я вже сказав, завтра ми займемося програмою,
змістом.
Я думаю, це те, що хочуть знати виборці та
громадяни,
і вони не хочуть постійних дискусій навколо
особистостей.
Говорить Тіно Хрупалла, старий та новий лідер AfD.
Щиро дякую.
З радістю.
Ми записали інтерв'ю о 21-й годині вечора з причин,
пов'язаних з розкладом.
Ханно, ти починаєш огляд новин
із ситуації в Україні.
Так, Крістіане.
Президент України Зеленський відвідав
лінію фронту на півдні країни вперше від початку
загарбницької війни з Росією.
У Миколаєві він оглянув руйнування,
після чого вручив відзнаки
місцевому голові військової адміністрації
та меру.
Тільки вчора було завдано ракетного удару
по одному з житлових районів міста, двоє людей
загинуло,
20 дістали поранень.
Федеральний президент Штайнмаєр відкрив
всесвітню художню виставку «Documenta»
в Касселі, а також торкнувся теми антисемітизму,
що розгорнулася навколо виставки.
«Критика ізраїльської політики дозволена, -
сказав Штайнмаєр, -
але там, де критика Ізраїлю ставить під сумнів
його існування,
межу переступили.»
Колектив кураторів з Індонезії був
звинувачений у тому,
що включив до експозиції художників,
які нібито підтримують бойкот Ізраїлю
або налаштовані антисемітськи.
Майже 11 років після масового вбивства на
норвезькому острові Утойя
було відкрито національний меморіал
пам'яті жертв.
На поромному причалі, що з'єднує острів із
материком,
зараз знаходиться меморіал із 77 бронзовими
стовпами,
по одному на кожного загиблого.
Разом з принцом Хоконом сім'ї загиблих та ті,
хто вижив,
відкрили меморіал.
2011 року правий екстреміст Брейвік убив 8 людей
бомбою в урядовому районі Осло,
а потім розстріляв 69, переважно молодих,
учасників
політичного літнього табору на острові Утойя.
Чемпіонат світу з плавання у Будапешті
розпочався
з першою медаллю для німецької команди.
Лукас Мертенс завоював срібло у фіналі запливу
на 400 метрів вільним стилем.
Найшвидшим був лише австралієць Віннінгтон -
1,63 секунди.
Бразилець Коста завоював бронзу.
У Лізі чемпіонів із гандболу для «Кіля» сьогодні
ввечері
йшлося про місце у фіналі.
Рекордсмени Німеччини зустрілися в Кельні
з володарями титулу - «Барселоною».
Глядачі спостерігали справжню битву.
«Кіль» у білому особливо добре зіграв
у першому таймі з великим рахунком.
Патрік Венцек раз у раз виходив
з оборони «Барселони».
Але були і помилки.
Іспанці грають швидко -
до перерви "Кіль" поступається 18:19 у
«Фіналі чотирьох» турніру в Кельні.
До цього воротар збірної Андреас Вольфф
грав у недільному фіналі із чемпіонами Польщі.
Кільцям не вдалося здобути перемогу.
Алекс Гомес виділяється у складі «Барселони», що
захищає своє чемпіонське звання.
У результаті каталонці явно перемагають.
«Кіль» програв півфінал з рахунком 30:34,
але на рахунку північногерманців, як і раніше,
чотири титули переможців Ліги чемпіонів.
Лотерейні номери цієї суботи:
18 – 23 – 26 – 37 – 45 – 46.
Суперчисло - 2.
Як завжди, без гарантій.
Якою буде погода
після сьогоднішніх високих температур?
На півночі завтра очікується дощ.
На решті території більшість часу буде сонячно,
пізніше можливі грози.
На півдні та південному сході буде до 39 градусів,
на північному заході від 20 до 31 градуса, на островах 16.
У понеділок та середу погода буде мінливою,
у вівторок переважно сонячно.
Сильна спека добігає кінця, але буде, як і раніше,
тепло:
у середу від 19 до 30 градусів.
На цьому ми прощаємося з вами цієї літньої ночі,
до завтра.
Наступні новини о 23.45:
«Heute Xpress» із Моріцем Нойсом.
До побачення, приємного вечора.